a third of the mornings I wake up I ask
myself am I still me or am I someone
else
I I ask myself that just I know you're
getting deep in the morning man
no I never really needed coffee that's
just that's my jump start [ __ ] I start
my morning like this oh Jesus I gotta do
this again
[Music]
this is Star Talk this is the Halloween
show Chuck always good to have you there
always a pleasure uh stand-up comedian
and actor
acting like a comedian oh is that what
that was okay it is
so today we're going to talk about
uh I guess uh zombies again but in a
more sort of analytic scientific context
we're going to talk about ghosts we're
going to talk about
reanimating
putrified life
or just dead life right if that phrase
can ever even be uttered so my Lord by
now he stinketh
thank you
okay A little Lazarus reference there oh
is that what that was okay yeah yeah no
that's well of course I Think Jesus made
the first zombie and people don't even
realize good credit for that Jesus made
the first zombie
you nailed that one there it is there it
is
um and that was before he became a
zombie himself well there you go right
he was spotted in town after he wrote
send your letters to Neil the grass type
not called Jesus
[Laughter]
so so anyhow neither you nor I have any
expertise in this field so we're we're
we have two guests we're going to start
off with one first uh David andrejovic I
think that I pronounce your name right
David
close enough
Yes actually this was this was pathan
yeah oh God Andrea okay yes yes uh your
associate research scientist in
neuroscience at the Yale School of
Medicine so you're coming to us from I
presume New Haven Connecticut yes yes
and you co-authored a recent study and
you managed to restore key cellular
functions
in the cells of a pig
that had been dead for an hour wow like
whoa okay Frankenstein pig is what that
is Franken Pig Franken Pig
but did it have electrodes and like you
know a Tesla coil and bumps in its neck
yeah I know bolts in his neck and you
have to throw your arms up and said it
is alive
yeah and then right afterwards you go
it's alive it's not bacon
disappoint you there uh yeah please
straighten this out I mean we are you
know our imagination was just flying
there so what did you actually do please
yeah so did look uh as cool as you
described how uh it's basically what
they've done is we developed this
technology that is
capable of restoring certain seller
functions one hour after that bigs as
you said and how we achieved that is
basically
um and actually how what cons like what
makes this technology uh possible is two
components so one is a machine perfusion
device which is similar to those uh
Heart and Lung machines that you hear
about in clinics uh sometimes called
Echo machines or which stands for extra
portfolio membrane oxygenation
but I knew that yeah
okay okay go on yeah it's basically like
a heart to lung machine right and then
uh we also have we also made the
synthetic perfusate which is something
uh sort of a synthetic blood which we
mixed with animals blood and restore the
circulation first in order to achieve
this kind of bring cells uh healthy
again making cells healthy again and so
on
so you you you you you kind of created
some blood created a blood flow
oxygen to cells and thereby revive the
cells themselves because that's what
they need you kind of fed them and then
they they kind of came back to life
exactly that's the key so the key was to
restore the circulation of course and we
for for that we needed the machine
and then also we developed this solution
that has a lot of different components
for example it has like what vitamins
amino acids it has chemistry any good
chemistry going on in there yes exactly
like a drug cocktail an oxygen carrier
and so on and however to to reach out to
those cells uh to restore their function
uh basically uh we needed the machine so
they work together to achieve our goal
wait a minute David are you saying you
did not use bolts of electricity come on
now and for yeah unfortunately
the next time you next time you do it
just fake the electricity fake the
electricity man so that we can because
we need that we've got to have that you
know and also make sure that the roof of
wherever you are opens up
and that there's there's a table that
rises up you gotta hit the Moonlight
yeah yeah you need the Moonlight and the
rising table I forgot about that Chuck
yeah you need the rising table you need
the Moonlight coming you need all that
let it do it at night all right
so the term we've heard is re animation
is that a fair fair term for this what
you're doing so I would uh we did
because we focused on the cellular level
so reanimation usually refers to like
other other uh layer layers or levels of
of function like a horror organism
functioning so since we focus just on
the server level would be
you wrote it like that so we said we
mentioned oh you're restoring certain
seller functions and so on so
we wanted to keep it conservative
because I know that we knew that
everybody would think about zombie pigs
immediately so yeah of course but okay
so so this brings the question
uh uh an hour is sort of a nice
convenient amount of time rather than
just one minute or five minutes you know
right we all know people have been dead
or it's Hearts stopped for that time and
you you zap them back to life so how
much thought went into it being an hour
as opposed to three hours six hours 12
hours a day yeah what what sets your
limits there and what is the level of
cellular degradation at an hour
yeah so it allows that that that says oh
we did something yeah so that's those
are both uh good questions I mean like
one hour just sounds sounds as you
mentioned it's it's really it has a lot
of implications that we can achieve it
at one hour and also what we have uh
discovered before in our lab and also
with this study confirmed is that like
when sales uh uh are die it's not like
uh instantaneous event it's like a more
protracted series of events and because
of that there's this like time window in
which we can intervene uh stop that
process and restore the seller function
not to put a word in your mouth but what
you're saying is that the act of dying
and death is itself a Continuum yes it's
on the cellular level definitely it is
uh it's from my perspective yes but see
that's that's amazing because it's
amazing because we we think of binary
terms you're either alive or you're dead
dead right you're not one-third alive
and two-thirds there so this could
change the vocabulary this could change
people's awareness of whatever I'm on
the depth Spectrum on the Dance Spectrum
[Laughter]
okay so so what this tells me is what
you hinted at is different parts of the
cell made diet sooner than other parts
and so the cocktail you feed it
plus the electricity just for show the
cocktail you feed it um will have to
know you have to know what part of the
cell needs reinvigorating at what time
after death and that would presumably
change as the minutes go by
yes yes so almost like
uh now science knows they're just not
one way for cell to die there are so
many different uh processes that can
happen and cells can buy in different
ways so basically what we have tried to
achieve besides of course restoring this
like environment for the cell uh to be
healthy again and to restore its
function uh we also wanted to inhibit or
stop these different processes and
that's what we targeted with our drug
cocktail so what what are the I mean
I'm just trying to take a practical
applications when this let's say is
fully developed is this something where
I kind of don't have oxygen going to my
brain for a long time and instead of
being brain dead you're able to help me
not be that or I guess what are the
limits of this yeah we can see where
it's starting where can you take it
so I think like well brain is most
susceptible to ischemia to to loss of
blood flow and and it's being notorious
for that uh however some reviews I'd
like that word ischemia ischemia it's
like yeah lots of blood flow okay
essentially thank you that's a word
and uh so what what happens like we're
at the moment not sure how it will
reflect all the other organs and like
what's the future will bring us but we
hope that at least we can restore uh
these vital organs such as kidney liver
heart lungs pancreas even that we have
tested uh in our in our study and that
we can by doing so increase organ donor
pull and use this organs for transplant
oh wow so wow like to go that far and
and talk about brain recovery and so on
we're kind of not
you're not sure to which extent bring
can recover still because it's extremely
susceptible to experience but maybe some
other organs might work
so I just hope
that this will increase the organic well
no you could end up saving so many lives
because you're extending the life of an
organ so that gives it that gives it
more time to reach the the person who
needs it exactly right but but a
question though if if
um
I can get what you're saying with regard
to the cell but an organ is a collection
of countless cells all acting in some
harmonious way and that's not what
you're you're not bringing the organ
back to life you're bringing a cell back
to life how does how do you bring the
organ itself back to life or do all the
cells say hey let's just pick up where
we left off
enter the electricity in the bolts
we'll get there Chuck we're trying to
get there
maybe maybe that was the ingredient that
we needed there
because we want so uh a celery so this
was all like uh like more of a proof of
concept study so we wanted to show
whether we can even do that or not after
one hour so and of course we were we
weren't even expecting this to happen
so yet alone seeing the whole organ
functioning again but uh in order to
whole organ function again we we at
least you need a cell function again
then maybe a tissue function and then a
whole organ function where all the cells
are communicating together doing their
functions like a concert and so on so
maybe eventually we'll come to that
point gotcha all right you're using a
machine to to tell the cell what to do
so then why couldn't you extend it to
kind of let the machine kind of be like
an endocrine you know uh traffic cop and
tell the whole organ what to do
oh that's a that's an interesting
question uh well basically we we kind of
uh limited ourselves to to six hours uh
because that was uh we had some
experience from uh some previous track
in our lab and also wanted to see
whether like it's more it was more of a
yes or no question at that point so
whether we can see that or not and then
now when we know okay we can see that
okay now it's actually uh a next uh Next
Step so for example exactly this uh we
are trying to do two things at once uh
we're trying to do two things and once
in the future one is of course to maybe
prolong this perfusion time maybe to
like 24 hours or even longer and then
the other aspect would definitely be uh
to even transplant these organs to other
animals and then see whether like to
which extent this organ has recovered in
its function wow now your background is
in Neuroscience uh but this feels not to
put divide dividing lines everywhere but
this feels more like sort of Cell
Biology so where does your Neuroscience
training uh help feed what's going on
here so that's a that's a question of
what's the question well I I was
fortunate enough so I went to med school
before and then I joined the lab uh uh
as a neuroscientist and then this whole
technology started in a Brain before
and then uh so the slab actually our lab
uh uh uh published a study back in 2019
showing that it can restore certain
seller functions in the brain after
after prolonged ischemia almost blood
flow and then after that uh everybody
was just excited about the findings and
uh my so Dr says my boss phone couldn't
uh stop ringing because everyone from a
different perspective would call him and
and would ask him like oh can we try
this and deliver have you tried this on
the heart or on the kidney and so on
so what he decided to do is he decided
to do like a shotgun approach like let's
see
whether this can work on every organ at
once and so I was fortunate enough to be
that uh that was the time when I joined
the lab and because of my background and
also in medicine so he uh he thought
that would be a good person to lead this
project wow and so is there a is there
an ethical component of what you're
doing where you bring in maybe a
bioethicist to to look over your
shoulder and advise on where this is or
can go
yes I'm glad that you mentioned that so
the whole study was being uh like
overseen by two committees so one was of
course Yale's institutional Animal Care
news committee and also we had an
external advisory committee to help us
plan uh the experiments to help us uh
like the like develop the anesthesia
protocol so people so animals would not
be in distressed and so on and also to
use the the least number of animals
possible for this type and of course uh
we uh in our in our one of the authors
of our manuscript is a bioethicist
Stephen Layton from from Yale as well
okay so so we got we got you covered on
that end that's good yes because you
know uh because I'm pretty sure you can
tell us during the break which we're
gonna have to take in just a minute uh
how many zombies you've stored in the
basement
just you can save that for the break but
I got one last question here is there
any sort of key chemical ingredient that
seems to be the most important or is
it's such a tale that it's really the
full mixture of them yeah yeah
unfortunately we would also like to know
the answer to that question so we can we
can you know uh sell it on the market
it's it's it's it's the it's the it's
everything all together uh that we think
it's what makes the difference so okay
it's also for us we have we're
constantly asking uh ourselves a
question like can we somehow
estimate which drug is doing you know a
percentage-wise exactly
but this is just impossible there's so
many different compounds and also when
we're doing experiments we're doing one
experiment per day and so it will
literally take us like years and years
to uh to even a value to control all the
variables right yes exactly you just
think it's it's too complex too many
variables so after the experiment
um did the pig have a taste for brains
the French and I didn't eat brains did
he no no no no but I'll tell you this
just since we are Halloween here uh uh
pigs correct me if I'm wrong uh in a
full-grown sort of hog has organs
approximately the size of that of humans
right so they make very good sort of
human substitutes in these kinds of
studies you would do this for a pig
rather than a mouse because for for just
that reason is that is that correct yes
absolutely there's a there's the reason
why so David thanks for this bit of
insight and some exposure to your work
here we will monitor that space and
maybe bring you back when you actually
finally do come to your senses and use
electrodes
so we learned you can restore and
reanimate individual cells and possibly
even whole organs but what about
restoring your Consciousness what is
consciousness is it something that can
be restored and what what's the latest
on that what a mystery Consciousness has
always been and may continue to be when
we come back Consciousness expert George
NewsHour after the break
we're back start talk the Halloween
edition I got Chuck nice with me Jack
hey all right so we learned about
reanimating cell functions after they've
been dead for an hour and even organs
that the cells comprise and what about
sort of reanimating Consciousness well
we can take that to its most basic level
because Chuck when you go under
anesthesia are you conscious right and
then when ACU wears off then you sort of
wake you're not asleep Neil right yeah I
am not conscious right now okay
all right we'll get in line and talk to
our expert about that one we've got
George moshour George is the Robert
sweet professor and chair of
anesthesiology at University of Michigan
medical school and wait a minute this
man is also the director of the Michigan
psychedelic Center oh we know what
decades went to college in that's like a
guy I want to be friends with we know
when this this man went to school uh and
founder of the center for Consciousness
science I love it what a frontier
Consciousness is on every level so
George welcome to StarTalk thank you so
much for having me yeah so so tell me
what is what is a clinical definition of
Consciousness versus unconsciousness
just just so we're on the same page here
yeah that's such a great question it's
actually a really big question because
Consciousness by definition is
subjective and yet all of our
determinations about Consciousness and
other people and other species relates
to behavior and we make inferences based
on a responsiveness
um and in the clinical setting really
it's about following commands it's about
responsiveness it's about interactivity
and most of the time that works
sometimes we can be led astray by making
inferences that somebody who's
unresponsive is actually unconscious so
so are you that sounds more like
awareness because like you say you're
unconscious when you sleep but you're
dreaming your heart is beating you're
yeah you know the brain is still lit the
brain is still lit yeah yeah yeah so
during general anesthesia there's
actually a lot of brain function that is
preserved I mean you're still
controlling a lot of autonomic functions
there's still uh activity going on in
your primary sensory cortices
connectivity
representation
anesthesia is probably more about the
higher order integration that brings
together all of this processing to
create that emergent property of
subjectivity that we're experiencing
right now
so how does this connect to uh we read
about in their movies that try to talk
about near-death experiences where if I
can recount what people say they are
they're sort of clinically dead in some
way they're hard stopped and I don't
know that this always includes being
brain dead but certainly the heart has
stopped and then they're brought back
and then they give a whole story of
where they went where they visited what
light in the sky they looked at White
Light it was huge it was so bright but
yet it did not hurt my eyes oh and it
and yet they're on an operating table
where they're lights above them I know
so what's what's going on during what we
think of as ndes
yeah great question and it's a great
example of where somebody who is
behaviorally quiescent they're not doing
anything is actually having this really
rich Vivid phenomenology that can
transform their lives and actually it uh
it's interesting it gets back to that
question of the electricity uh that you
were discussing with your your previous
guest because what has been identified
in dying humans and also in some very
well-controlled animal studies is that
around the time of death there's
actually a surge of electrical activity
that goes on the brain this surge can
actually be coherent and well organized
and it's being explored as a
neurobiological basis for the near-death
experience wow is this also my whole
life unfolded in front of me right yeah
that kind of thing is that
yes I mean it's um you know there's
still a a big bridge uh to be crossed
between that neurobiology and some of
the phenomenology that you're referring
to and these are really characteristic
descriptions that go back to Antiquity
seeing the tunnel the light the life
recall
um so lots to do in terms of bridging
that Gap but I think of what has
occurred in the past decade or so uh is
a progress in terms of understanding
that there can be a neurobiology to this
there can be neural correlates
Consciousness around the time of death
so that takes it out of the metaphysical
or Supernatural realm into the
neuroscientific realm is it possible
because our brains are just liars I mean
anybody who I mean whatever you think
you saw you most likely didn't and where
really malleable and and very easily
influenced is it possible that that
people have these very similar
experiences because they've heard that
people have these very similar
experiences
it's uh it's a great question you know
whether or not this
um kind of folks psychology or common
mythology around death yeah and people
report that but actually this is this is
where the the science uh is is quite
helpful and when I with my colleague
jimo borsigan here at the University of
Michigan published an article almost 10
years ago in animals showing that there
were neural correlates of Consciousness
after experimentally induced Cardiac
Arrest or respiratory arrest there are a
lot of people who had near-death
experiences who reached out to thank us
because they felt like that neurobiology
actually helped validate their
experience so is it possible that there
is some psychological influence it is
but I do think that there is an emerging
consensus that there there might be some
clear neurobiology that's going on
around the time of death wow because
we're all we're all the same species so
you'd expect some common reaction to the
common causes is that that's where
you're going there right right and it
occurs across species too so we're
seeing very similar findings in rodents
that we are in humans in terms of that
surge of high frequency activity so can
you set a time limit to how long a brain
can be quote brain dead before it gets
reanimated so that you could you know
tell us that the Frankenstein brain
Abbey normal in the jar off the shelf in
formaldehyde that it's just that we
don't know how to reanimate it or can
you say it can never be reanimated based
on everything we know about physiology
so first of all I want to make a
distinction between what some people
refer to as clinically dead which is
primarily from the cardiovascular
perspective so the heart is stopped with
brain death which is a cessation of all
brain function both cortical and
subcortical brainstem activity so I
think what we're talking about in the
context of the near-death experience
um is that cardiovascular death where
you do have residual activity
um again it's a spectrum and it's a
process
so it's it's not clear to me what the
the timing is this is extremely
difficult to study we see the surge of
activity in animals at around 30 seconds
after cardiac arrest and afterwards you
do get that the acquiescence of brain
activity but this is happening on on
both sides of the bride if you will it's
happening across the Spectrum so in
these Critical Care patients you're
seeing the spikes of activity prior to
death and there are other examples for
example terminal Lucidity which is where
Alzheimer's patients for example
um who have been non-communicative for
years suddenly start to become Lucid
they start to interact right before
their death so we think that there's a
spectrum of that brain activation that's
going on but but the the temporal window
has yet to be defined but wait a minute
if you know that happens that in
principle is reproducible
whatever is going on right to to to
reanimate the out the severe Alzheimer's
patient you this is we're talking about
science here right so whatever that is
you duplicate it and then put it in a
pill and then let everybody take it
right
absolutely and and I've worked with a
group uh from the National Institute of
Health to make that claim that these
examples of terminal Lucidity really
represent an opportunity to understand
that neurobiology that it's not just
structural degeneration there's some
functional component and if we can
bottle that if you will understand it
reproduce it it could be a pathway
toward reanimating cognition uh and
communication that's amazing by the way
uh Alzheimer's terrible terrible disease
grandfather died of it and uh what it
taught me is that every single thing
that you do
uh your brain is how can I put it
conscious that you were doing it when
you swallow you think it's involuntary
your brain doesn't think that's
involuntary your brain is actually
saying swallow and it's crazy when you
watch somebody lose every single bodily
function uh because instead of sequence
thank you yes it's crazy it's crazy
right right right so George let's let's
get back to Consciousness for the moment
now that you've basically admitted that
combined with our first segment we can
make conscious zombies that's really
what you just said I'm pretty sure
um but what what is there agreement on
what Consciousness is I guess people can
Define it but the fact that books are
continually written about it tells me we
know very little because once you
understand scientifically a subject you
don't have to keep writing books on it
to say Consciousness explained or new
discoveries so I I think to myself that
that Consciousness studies is still kind
of in its infancy because of this am I
wrong and that's why you're conscious
because you think therefore you are
thank you Chuck foreign
science and even if you know you think
back historically Consciousness as a
subject of scientific study was really
delegitimized for most of the 20th
century so it's it's the 1990s the
mid-1990s when this formal study of
Consciousness started to emerge and
decades later we're still asking
fundamental questions for example are
the neural correlates of Consciousness
in the front of the brain or in the back
of the brain and and this is that's
coming up in titles in neuroscientific
journals I'm not exaggerating the
coarseness of that so for as much as
we've learned about how to manipulate
neural circuitry over the past decades
there's still some really fundamental
questions in terms of where
consciousness us is happening or
processed in the brain the nature I have
is uh in physics you know quantum
physics is a is a fundamental branch of
the field uh but the mysterious things
that happen that we can describe with
high accuracy but we don't really
understand what the hell is happening
you know particles disappear and
reappear and we can describe it we know
what they're doing mathematically but
can you say do you understand it nope
that's just how nature behaves what
concerns me is I see people trying to
apply the mysteries of quantum physics
to the mysteries of Consciousness as
though taking our ignorance in one place
somehow helps the ignorance in the other
rather than making it just doubly
ignorant works with my opinion there
yeah no really interesting deal and uh
you know since it's a Halloween theme we
can talk about spooky action at a
distance because one of the one of the
theories within that Quantum realm is
that the kind of integration that needs
to go on for conscious experience to
happen is mediated by a Quantum process
or Quantum entablement
and the the argument has been as you
just very well described that just
because one thing has a similar kind of
mysterious quality is another doesn't
mean that they should be connected now
we've actually studied uh this in the
context of anesthesia because some
people have posited that anesthetics
work by disrupting this Quantum
interaction and we could talk about it
if you want but the long and short of it
is we applied
um General anesthetics liquid ether to
uh photons both classical and entangled
and I'm not a Quantum physicist I'm not
going to pretend like I am but people
are starting to uh address this
empirically so we can either move
forward or or just leave that discourse
behind now I know that Roger Penrose is
very famous decorated uh physicist
astrophysicist has stepped into the
Consciousness realm but let me remind
people by invoking Quantum uh causes for
so much of what's described but allow me
to say in this moment that his Nobel
Prize
granted just a couple of years ago was
for black holes not for Consciousness so
just to be clear all right yes yes and
he he was part of that wave in the 1990s
and his his work you know uh really
stimulated that line of thinking yeah
and I think we shouldn't ignore it but
just I I don't like explaining things
with things I don't yet understand that
that's right that's that never said well
with me you have to approach it
empirically yeah exactly sure so if
you're looking for you know whether uh
you know you're looking at the a place
in the brain that houses Consciousness
we know that the brain itself does house
Consciousness and uh whether it's just
these electrical you know impulses that
are firing all the time and when that
electricity is plug is pulled we're gone
or something else could you take it and
put it someplace else if you were to
find it and locate it that sounds like
something for the next segment chuck oh
okay what you're talking about uploading
your Consciousness that the people yeah
yeah that's kind of what you just said
there yeah okay yeah
big question right is there something
special about this neurobiological
substrate or is this just about
functional relationships of
electrochemical activity that could be
reproduced in a non-biological context
and we're going to get to that in the
next segment let's take a break now and
when we return on our Halloween edition
we're talking about reanimating cells
reanimating Consciousness
um zombies Frankenstein and uh we're
gonna have to throw in ghosts somehow in
this third segment just just to round
out the Halloween experience you're
watching possibly listening to start
talk we'll be right back
we're back on start talk our third and
final segment of our Halloween edition
we're talking about reanimating dead
cells that's actually been done and
accomplished in a lab in New Haven and
at Yale and we're talking about uh
Consciousness its existence its absence
reanimating it uh with an
anesthesiologist so first David
andrejovic thanks for coming back to the
show for this third and final segment
and we've got George mushur uh who is
George let me correct me with I'm wrong
with your full title here a chair of
anesthesiology University of Michigan
medical school and founding director of
the Michigan psychedelic Center we
didn't even touch that subject yet
Perhaps but let's let's pick up where we
left off uh there's a question Chuck
what was you what was that question when
you left I was just saying if you can
locate it can you take it in place it
someplace else your Consciousness put
your Consciousness somewhere other than
yourself I love that question so George
what do you have there
I have anything I don't know I don't
know
very good against answer ever yes that
that's about as honest as you can get I
I have to be honest because you know
really it's a foundational question as
to whether or not Consciousness is
purely neurobiological or is is it
functional and functionalism is a you
know one approach to thinking about
Consciousness which is this is about the
characteristics of a system not
necessarily a set of neural systems but
I think that you know the the first
approach is we have to understand it
better in humans who can report their
conscious experience before we start
thinking about how it gets reproduced
elsewhere of course because if you don't
if you if you don't really understand it
in humans to then say let's upload it
somewhere it doesn't mean make any sense
right but I I will add did you not
George did you not
in different words speak of what
evolutionary biologists call emergence
in evolution where you can study a bird
down to the cellular level and you will
never know
that birds together will flock
that information is not contained in the
cellular biology of the bird it's only a
collective emergent phenomenon so that
if you can't identify Consciousness as
in the behavior of cells could it be
emergent in The Ensemble of the behavior
of cells that comprise the entire brain
Neil that I mean that's my inclination
and that's my perspective not everybody
shares it but I do think this is more of
a network level Dynamic and a network
level emergence of subjective experience
and I think that speaks directly to the
question of
reanimation regeneration if you're and
and we think about it even in the
operating room we're reanimating from
the anesthetized state that you know
that is a process of of reconnection and
re-emergence in fact we call it
emergence from anesthesia you do okay
yeah but if the sum of the parts is
greater than or even different
than the individual Parts how do you how
do you find it how like what what are
you able to do maybe that very question
is wrong right like how do you find the
flock the flocking in a bird you can't
right maybe the very question is flawed
right yeah just just saying we try to
approach that experimentally by various
measures of integration and brain
function uh such as connectivity
um and and how the electrical activities
relate to one another to to try to grasp
that we we do Dynamic analyzes but yes
it is uh it's a difficult question but I
would agree that Consciousness is not
going to be found at an individual
cellular level it's going to be at a
systems level so I got a question
connecting back to George here because
when you anesthetize someone they can no
longer feel pain there's a lot of their
body that has shut down uh other parts
still work of course the heart still
beats so how is it that your anesthesia
can do what the suite of things you need
it to do but not shut down Georgia's
organs that he would otherwise try to
animate that would otherwise be
non-functioning
yes so I mean if you turn the anesthetic
high enough you can shut down the organs
there's no doubt about that at the
concentrations that we use to suppress
Consciousness I really do believe it's a
kind of uh disassembly of that emergence
uh process you're you're creating
inhospitable conditions for the
emergence to occur for the connection
for the communication to occur so in the
brain you can still have local areas
that are functioning in meaningful ways
even representing the environment and
we've tested that empirically but it's
that higher order synthesis that seems
to be disruption and just to clarify
something you mentioned earlier just to
throw a little more physics in the
conversation the the whole idea of a
quantum entanglement by the way anything
on the level of atoms and molecules
and and the Deep chemistry that goes on
among them is quantum the quantum forces
are operating all throughout so quantum
entanglement is you have two particles
that know about each other's existence
from separated by a distance and then
something can happen in one where the
other one responds instantaneously to it
because they're entangled and instant
and not faster than the speed of light
it's an instantaneous uh in the in the
lingo of quantum physics instantaneous
collapse of the wave function because
the two particles share the same wave
essentially and so if Consciousness goes
beyond just a local spot in the brain
and it really
surf's Quantum phenomenon then maybe
quantum entanglement really matters and
that's not just a frontier just wanted
to clarify a Vulcan mine meld oh the
Vulcan mind milk it can happen people
the Vulcan blind melb is a is a quantum
entanglement right
you heard it here people
so George can you re-animate a brain
do you think
not now just at some point
like we know
yeah David comes to you and said they're
brain dead you drag him off the table
and he said no I got this i got this put
them on my slab and I and I got this
yeah well uh again I don't know the
answer but the question really is going
to be you know what is re what is
reanimated are we reanimating cells uh
that are functioning and independent
ways and this gets back to the the organ
uh recovery
right yeah are we yeah absolutely or and
I think it's even more pertinent for the
brain are we going to be reanimating
that Network level emergent phenomenon
uh that is manifestos is consciousness
and I think those
those answers are going to be distinct
but so David how much of what you do
is
I mean I have to think at some level
there's
some electrochemical things happening
that's how we we're taught about the
brain right it's not just chemicals
there's like there's synapses uh you
know why else would electric shock
therapy work you know so uh is there no
electrochemistry going on when you
reanimate shell cells even if it's just
the chemistry that you introduce
so no unfortunately not again but I
would say uh so we kind of restored the
the environment of the cells and
actually we targeted their functions
because they were they were in that
process of dying but maybe in the future
like if you want to restore the whole
function of the of the whole organ we
might
do something like that like for example
in the heart we have seen also in our
study that we there is a restoration of
each heart cells uh cell individual
called cardiomyocyte actually but they
contract we can see that if you take a
tissue of the of the of the heart to
look at under the microscope we can see
they're they're Contracting however in
order to hard to function properly you
need them to to
communicate together and actually have
that heart chambers contract uh in life
synchronous ways yes coherently so
similar thing is in the brain you you
can have a single neuron or brain cell
firing but in order to actually I guess
get to the point of of Consciousness
awareness and so on they need to act
coherently there has to be a concert it
needs to be a concert exactly right
exactly right right so this level I mean
the heart it's well known you can uh
Elixir shocked the heart but for the
brain I I'm you're not that good
wow okay so so other than in the film
World War Z where the zombies somehow
could move really fast if metal serves
most zombies portrayed are kind of slow
moving and they even are a little bit
dim-witted and so the implications man
they've been dead it's tough give him a
cut him some slack
don't give him a trigonometry exam
so so what it says is the restoration of
life
um in these movies is possible but it's
a lesser version of what it was before
always so what we learn is that in a
zombie State they still function but in
a diminished condition not only
physically but also neurologically so is
there some
in your organs and in in the brain does
it like work fully or can it can there
be is there a spectrum of how it could
perform once you uh reanimate them let
me just start with David wow could it
half work
so that's that's a good like do we want
them to have work uh they lost the
question uh because what's the point if
uh let's say we want to if the goal of
our studies to recover the organs to be
able for transplantation like you don't
want to make them half work and then
because nobody would like uh to count it
hard cook the kids near the liver
they're just house working so but maybe
maybe this is just like a a one step we
have this analogy in our lab like if you
break a leg first you need to you're not
gonna run the next day there's you know
uh like a a time period where you need
to recover first start walking again and
then able to run after after some time
David I hate to be the first to tell you
but that saying is not deep
if you break your leg you're not going
to walk the next day I know we we say it
like this if you you crawl before you
walk so uh that's kind of how we say it
but yeah you guys are scientists you're
in a lab you've got to make things
difficult you got to make it yeah yeah I
get it all right so wait let me ask this
thing because Neil just bought a super
fascinating Point uh when you talk about
coming back
uh on a on a spectrum with respect to
Consciousness how much of Consciousness
is agency if you were to come back but
like half way you that's is that you I
mean like are you still really you and
how much of being you determines what
Consciousness is oh because by the way
George I
third of the mornings I wake up I ask
myself am I still me or am I someone
else
I I ask myself that just I know you're
getting deep in the morning man
no I never really needed coffee that's
just that's my jump start [ __ ] I start
my morning like this oh Jesus I gotta do
this again I wake up and I just am I
still me wow and so is there some
minimum expression of the brain function
where someone can say yeah I'm still me
right
wonderful philosophical question taking
it out of the realm of zombies I mean we
we try to probe this with inducing
reanimation from anesthesia in the
experimental setting where we are
stimulating with electricity or we're
driving a certain set of neurons and we
see behaviors that emerge and we've
asked the question actually in these
terms are these zombie rats now they're
they're they look they look awake but do
they have phenomenology that's
associated with that that wayfulness uh
we think about it with the emergence of
patients from general anesthesia what
what's that minimal for yourself that is
emerging and and that process of the the
self-reconstituting after an anesthetic
leads to very similar questions is this
the same person emerging as is the one
that went under so I think uh not
addressing the the really big questions
but utilizing anesthesia as an
experimental model can help get at some
of those questions of the emergence of
the self and the the the pathway or
trajectory of that self-reconstituting
wow that's crazy because even if you
just were to stop certain parts of the
brain from talking to one another you
could dramatically change someone's
personality and make them kind of feel
like I'm I'm not really me I would never
do that and
we interviewed Oliver Sacks a few years
back if you're interested you can check
out our archives and what we learned in
that interview because he has he's has
he suffers if I can use that word the
condition of is it face blindness he
does not recognize faces whatever the
word is for that and I shouldn't use the
word suffer because I asked him uh if
you could go back and take some magic
pill and remove this Affliction would
you and he said no he wouldn't because
the fact that he had that Affliction is
what sent him on this journey to study
neuroscience and he published books he's
got a feature movie made after him my
question to you is well I learned that
at one point he looked in the mirror and
did not recognize who he was looking at
that's how severe that face blind is
manifested within him and so are we to
say that something broke in his
consciousness
yes well I mean this gets uh back to
um you know Chuck's earlier point which
is there's so much that we take for
granted that is all wired and encoded
and processed I mean we just assume that
if we see our base we know it's ours
there's some people who can't recognize
that you know the hand that's attached
to them is theirs that that body
ownership is disrupted so the conscious
experience is there you see in the face
the patient seeing their hand now we're
getting to another level of self this is
me this is my hand this is my face and
so there's a there's really a spectrum
of conscious experience from that
foundational just sensation of the world
a sense of self and then putting all
that together
wow by the way if I just want to say if
you smoke enough marijuana you can look
at your hand and it's not yours anymore
either
no
says the man who runs the Psychotherapy
Institute
so so George I say publicly and tell me
if I'm out of line here
that first the brain
barely works
well enough to interpret objective
reality so that when people start
stirring in chemicals
the the assumption that somehow they
have a deeper understanding of reality
from my from where I stand cannot
possibly be true it might be some
different reality but not an objective
reality so the psychedelics that you
presumably study as founding director of
the Psychedelic Institute uh what would
you say is the long-term goal of that
because it can't possibly be let me ask
the person on LSD what's really
happening here and that will advance my
science the scientific Frontier
um
yeah so I look at psychedelics in the
same way that I look at anesthetics
they're they're tools to manipulate
Consciousness allow us to study the
brain and study perception and
Aesthetics help us modulate the level of
Consciousness psychedelics help us
modulate the content of Consciousness by
the way I don't know if you knew this
but alcohol also influences your State
of Consciousness just in case you didn't
know that so I put that in your in your
list absolutely that goes that's uh goes
along with the anesthetic actually
acting on very similar assistance so I
think these are tools
um you know I I don't uh romanticize or
stigmatize research with psychedelic
drugs uh we need to be rigorous we need
to be responsible for me it's really
about understanding the brain not
um you know using this as a tool to
understand uh reality now some would
argue that your your phrase objective
real reality isn't meaningful because
it's the brain that's that's generated
those would be philosophers who don't
actually do science so those those
concerns do not well I mean but you're
talking about what's external you're
obviously correct that's why we have
machines excuse me no that's why we have
machines to make the freaking
measurement okay then we all gather
around the machine and say do you all
agree what this machine says and we say
yes and it didn't depend on whether you
had coffee or whether someone else okay
how awake
the closer you are to an objective
reality to the point where it repeats
often enough you move on to the next
problem however that is always external
okay the measurement the only way the
measurement can be made is because it is
external okay the only way it can be
observed there are some realities that
are not measurable
not yet
so we got to land This Plane here oh no
this is too much fun George again you
you were with the University of Michigan
David you're with Yale University great
to uh I have an academic Soul so I love
uh reaching out to the resources that
reside within the nation's universities
so thanks for being on Star Talk and
Chuck always good to have you man always
a pleasure this was fun all right this
has been start talk this is a Halloween
edition Neil deGrasse Tyson here you're
a personal astrophysicist as always keep
looking up
hot Peppa
[Music]